- [MyneAndYours Artist] I don't
think it matters who I am.
What really matters is the story.
I try to remove myself from the equation
by going under the name Myneandyours.
It's me being inspired by our experiences.
So, in a way I'm taking
what I feel is mine
and then I'm giving back
so it becomes yours.
(upbeat electronic music)
(upbeat funk music)
So, I've been here four years now.
I grew up in London and
after 28 years in London,
I felt that I needed a change.
What I wanted to do was to be involved
in the creation of a culture,
rather than just, you know, become a part of it.
And I felt like Dubai is the
place that I could do that.
I have Arab roots so it
was a place that I could,
kind of, integrate
with, not feel too lost,
but feel that I could contribute
to something interesting.
When I started, I wanted an identity.
I wanted a way for people
to recognize the work.
What's funny about the cloud
is, it wasn't a choice.
It was very much a doodle and,
before I knew it, people
were connecting with it.
And that's when I started to analyze
the entire idea of a symbol,
and how you can use a
symbol to make people think.
Dubai Design Ditrict, they asked me
to create something crazy.
And it was a perfect opportunity.
I wanted to create an
immersive environment.
What was great about painting the carpark
was that it's in such an unlikely place.
You would never expect it to be there.
I love anything to do with
the universe and space.
I'm always lost in this wonder
of our position in the
universe and who we are.
When I first proposed the idea to them,
it seemed like it was easily possible.
But, very quickly into the project,
we started to realize how
much trouble it actually was.
And painting a ceiling just
became more and more painful
the further that we went along.
The project was 32 nights, 50,000 stars,
560 clouds, 500 stencils,
and one trip to A&E.
Once you just go a tiny
bit beneath the surface
of what Dubai is, you
find out that there is
this huge creative community here,
and a great group of like-minded people
doing amazing things.
I guess before I came here,
I had no idea that that even existed.